so we got some rather disappointing news
today the Batman vs. Superman movie that
was originally going to come out in the
summer of 2015 has been pushed all the
way to the summer of 2016 a year later
now before I get into the reasons and
what they're talking about let's just
talk about how I feel that sucks it
sucks a year why couldn't it have been
like a couple months or something why
did it have to be a year it's not even
2015 yet I felt like the 2015 was a far
away to be anticipating such an awesome
assemblage of characters and now it's in
2016 so the quote that they released
basically said that we need more time to
realize our vision I understand that
that could mean anything you know it
could mean that our script sucks
it could mean Ben Affleck isn't liking
the way the story's going could means X
nighters and like the way the story is
going
it could mean Ben Affleck broke his leg
which a lot of people were kind of
speculating about but apparently is not
true at all
at least that's what I've heard this is
all just people speculating like Oh Ben
Affleck penis fell off or oh my god
Henry Cavill is right boobs shrunk we're
not gonna make this movie anymore what
happened more than likely it was none of
those reasons more than likely they
aren't entirely sure they've got the
best story yet and they want to make it
as good as it can be something came up
in regards to that maybe Ben Affleck was
like look this just isn't right we need
to make this better and now they're
gonna make it better who knows they
couldn't quite push it back to December
of 2015 because then it would be in
competition with Star Wars Episode seven
so they chose as early in the next
summer as possible that's cool I'm glad
they didn't make it like August of 2016
but still it's so disappointing for me
to hear this news because I was really
looking forward to that movie I'm a huge
fan of Batman and Superman nevertheless
it's very confusing for a fan like me of
these guys because it's like it's like I
was riding all my emotions on that
specific date okay
that's the date where I become a man
again 2015 is not as crowded anymore
after Pirates of the Caribbean five has
moved and now Batman Superman has moved
so it's becoming a less crowded year
with her still Mission Impossible 5 and
Star Wars and the Avengers 2 to look
forward to and bond still
to be an incredible year it's just
Superman but look all fanboy isms aside
here I really do think they're making a
good choice if it is about the story if
they're making a choice that is story
based because they want to present the
best movie they can and make the best
film they can then I am all for it take
your time make a good movie that's cool
because in the past whenever a filmmaker
has said you know what look we need more
time to work on this it's generally a
good choice because it shows that a
filmmaker isn't as concerned about
finances and things like that and coming
out at a certain time to make more money
that's what I'm worried this decision
might also be about and that would mean
that I do not like this choice this is
all behind the scenes stuff that I don't
know about but I got to say if they're
just moving it to a different date
simply because there's less competition
then not a big fan of the choice but I'm
really hoping that what it is is that
they're just trying to make the best
movie they can and that there are people
behind the scenes going you know what we
really need to perfect this we really
need to tweak this and make this the
best film we can if that's the case
that's fine it sucks though I'm still
looking forward to it but 2016 I can't
even think about that year 2014 just
started it's like it's not even
happening again I remember hearing about
that movie back before Batman Begins
came out do you know how long I've been
hearing about that movie come out
already please and please be good so
guys what do you think of this choice do
you think it's a good idea do you think
they're really trying to improve the
story or do you think it's some other
behind the scenes corporate BS financial
thing or something hopefully they're
really trying to perfect the film that's
what I'm hoping for guys as always
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes